I've never been much of a fan of music
videos and I think that's because I sort
of just like my music as music.
I like to close my eyes and focus on
what's happening sonically because
that's what music is.
It's something that you hear,
so that means I can be totally engrossed
and in love with beyonce,
his latest album,
and not care at all about the dozen
videos that came out with it,
but I don't know.
Maybe I'm in the minority here and the
truth is that despite music being an
oral medium,
it's long had an intimate relationship
with the visual,
so I want to talk about perhaps the most
iconic visual supplement in the history
of music,
but before we talk about that,
what about album covers in general these
days we perceive them as a kind of
visual statement,
like the album title or the song names
that help us situate the tone or the
feeling of what we're going to hear.
It granted that it stays within the
dimension of a square.
The options and styles are basically
limitless,
but in the beginning,
records packaging was surely
utilitarian.
The early 78 RPM gramophone records were
mostly outfitted with Brown paper or
cardboard sleeves to protect the
recording.
It wasn't until 1938 when Columbia
records hired Alex.
stine Weiss as its very first art
director that the idea of cover art came
into existence against the plane or
traditional design of early covers.
Stein Weiss's original eyecatching art
initiated just a huge boom in sales and
the market followed as it always does
when something works.
Record stores were refigured so that
instead of just seeing the bindings like
books on a shelf,
consumers were encouraged to flip
through the covers.
This all points to just how important
the cover art was to the marketing of
the product.
And music is a product.
It's a commodity that people consume and
since you can't buy the band itself,
and since the music has no spacial
dimension,
the album cover emerged as the standard
for the commodity to be purchased.
This explains the rise of photography on
album covers and what's called the
personality cover.
You know,
one of those covers where it's just a
photograph of the band or musician,
still pretty popular today.
A perfect example of this personality
cover can be seen on the Beatles first
album.
Please,
please meet.
Look at those bright smiling faces
staring warmly into the camera lens.
As Susan Sontag once brilliantly said in
its simplest form,
we have in a photograph surrogate
possession of a cherished person or
thing.
As their career advanced,
the Beatles seemed to become darkly
aware of their status as commodities,
perhaps nowhere more plainly
acknowledged that on the cover of their
fourth album,
aptly titled Beatles for sale,
featuring another of the personality
cover this time without the warmth and
the smiles.
By the time sergeant pepper's emerge,
the Beatles had already begun
challenging the conventions with popular
music and its role in culture,
and this extended to the album covers
too.
First in rubber soul with it's distorted
image and funky tight face.
Then with revolver for which they
employed their friend and artists,
Klaus Vorman,
we did a kind of 19 sixties update of
Victorian illustrator Aubrey beardsley
famous black ink drawings.
In other words,
the Beatles were leaders in expanding
and album covers function from a
marketing tool to a work of art in its
own right,
and that brings us back to what is
really the holy grail of album covers,
the Beatles' sergeant pepper's lonely
hearts club band,
a cover that explicitly engages the
audience in so many ways and critiques
and interpretations and comparisons and
contrasts.
It's a cover that invites you in and a
perfect example of this is the immediate
challenge to just identify who all of
these people are.
What do Indian Gurus,
Karl Marx and Bob Dylan all have in
common?
The sergeant pepper's cover once you to
ask questions like this.
Now,
in one sense,
of course,
these people just represent the Beatles
interests and influences,
many of whom didn't make the final cut,
and yet by juxtaposing high brow artists
and thinkers like marks or Aubrey
Beardsley or George Bernard Shaw or
Dylan Thomas with pop icons like Bob
Dylan,
Marilyn Monro,
Marlin Brando,
and Shirley temple.
The Beatles signaled the breakdown and
mixing of high and low culture that they
themselves exemplified more than any
other artist with sergeant pepper.
The Beatles were in a posture of
challenge,
challenging everything they'd been up to
that point,
challenging the highbrow art critics to
abandon their exclusion of popular
culture,
challenging the listening public to
engage with something other than love
songs,
and the same for courts there were even
challenging the feelings of unity that
defined the summer of love in 1967,
delivering a suite of songs that
featured alienation and loss as much as
it did love and togetherness.
The album cover echoes these challenges
and adds some of its own by using the
technique of photo montage,
which manipulates photography's unique
ability to depict reality.
The Beatles blend and collapsed the
values of a number of different times
and places by staging the scene as a
performance and an audience.
The band challenges us to do,
dwell on the function both indeed.
These considerations were at the front
of their minds as the Beatles had only
recently elected to stop performing
live.
After the mayhem,
a beatle mania began to diminish the
quality of music while some accused them
of leaving their fans.
Hi.
The sergeant pepper's cover suggests the
opposite,
that the decision to stop touring was
out of respect for their fans,
not out of fear or contempt.
We should also note that the designer of
discover,
Peter Blake was a noted pop artists,
a style that used aspects of mass
culture to bring attention to the fuzzy
lines between art,
advertising,
news,
and all other forms of media.
The pop artists wanted to get people to
think about the process and
manufacturing of ar and how it's
categorizations and hierarchies are
largely arbitrary.
Blake and the Beatles design the
sergeant pepper cover as both a piece of
art and a product inside it's gatefold
sleeve.
The record had paper cutouts of the
pepper bans regalia adding to its
consumer kitsch value,
and yet it was also the first album to
display the lyrics on the packaging,
encouraging listeners to interrogate the
records,
intellectual content as well.
The truth is,
of course that music perhaps more
prominently than any other art form,
plays both parts as a commodity and an
aesthetic object,
and in many ways the two functions are
inseparable.
The Beatles knew this and maybe they
regretted it,
but they were self aware enough to see
that it was inescapable and if music had
to be marketed and if the visual was
going to be the vehicle of that John,
Paul,
George,
and Ringo were going to be as playful
here they were with everything else.
In the end,
this photograph of photographs levels a
critique on representation itself to
show how music is mediated by the
visual.
The Beatles put themselves on this cover
three times once as the wax figures of
the mop top beetles that they were once
as the fake pepper band and it's bright
and eye catching glory and finally as
themselves pictured not on the cover of
their album,
but by the effects of that cover in the
minds of everyone who looked at the real
Beatles can't be represented this way.
Not really not like this or like this or
like this.
The cover of sergeant pepper's lonely
hearts club band points to the truth.
What the Beatles themselves knew that
all music is invisible then in the news
today.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
If you are new to this channel,
I want to introduce myself on Evan,
the nerd writer.
I make weekly video essays that come out
on Wednesdays.
I'm about art and culture and philosophy
and whatever I find interesting that we
politic science.
Um,
I make this channel full time with your
help on Patrion.
So if you want to keep this channel
alive,
you want to see more of the nerd writer
click here or in the description and
pledge as little,
as a dollar per video.
Everything,
anything helps.
A Patriot is really my big push here.
So I appreciate your help and I'll see
you guys next Wednesday.